Hello everybody!  My name is Markiplier,
and welcome to Osiris: New Dawn.
Now, to be perfectly honest,
I don't know a lot about this game.
I didn't even know about it until today,
when I saw the that it was just released.
So,
It seems to be a space game. (great observation Mark)
AND I LOVE SPAAAACE!
(song starts playing) 'Ohh, that's soo coo-'
So,  it's early access. Which means that it's not fully done. So I'm gonna play it and try to learn about it without being too stupid-
Thanks for agreeing with me, Mr. Scientist Guy! I wish I could be an engineer but that's currently unavailable.
'Outlanders' or 'U.N.E.'.. Well Outlanders are red, so I guess that's gonna be me..
Nngeehh.. ehh... Yeah, good enough. Alright. Markimoo!
Uhh.. Mar-
Marki.. pooper. Markipooper!
Alright. Create!
[Reading] "Planet: Proteus 2. Singleplayer is perfect for practicing and learning your characters tools and abilities before jumping into live universe."
"Your character and progress-" Ohh, by the way.
This game is multiplayer. So, IIIII.. don't know.. how this is gonna go!
I don't even know if I'm even able to play multiplayer because, I don't know if it's ready yet.
But I'm gonna try it out. I will try it, I'm going to try singleplayer first because I don't wanna be stupid,
and uh, make everyone mad at me, but then
I will be trying multliplayer to see if there's someone out there that will put up with my stupidity
Prrrobably not, knowing my luck!
Oh, this is a slow- oh, there it goes.
Universe- ooh, ahh, eee, euu..(Markiplier sounds, wonderful Mark)okay we're all loaded.
Let's g- ooohh.
Ohh.
'Third moon of Thhhesius Prime'
What're we doin'..
[gasps]
'Suit breach'.. Ohh, I'm gonna die! Oh, what's that?
is that a robotic buddy?? Ohh, I'm gonna die! That's awesome! I LOVE SPACE! (No joke, Mark.)
Y'know, some people ask my why I don't like the ocean but I love space, it's because..
If I go in the ocean, I KNOW I'm gonna die. But if I go into space..
III mmight die! So, y'know, it's pretty cool, y'know, pretty cool.
Hey how's it goin'? Lil' bubblebutt, are you bubblebutt?
Flank right? Ca-tra-ca-control and repair *beep boop*
Wassat? Whooow I dunno what I'm doing. Set target. *grunt* That box, go get it.
Hey! Don't push me Bubblebutt! What do you think you're doing? Oh, you're cute, I like you.
Very attentive too.
Ya, I know it's a pretty cool box, huh? Ok, open the survival kit.
Ohhh. That's convoluted. Ok.
Structures *sing-song voice* Ohhhh we're freezing. Ok, habitat.
Oh. Ok, so I can build a habitat but I need resources.
And to gather-I have a baked potato! (Jack's Family?)
I'm channeling my inner Matt Damon!
Ok, a steamed carrot, water, bandage, med kit, multi-tool, chisel, patch-tape, map
Ok
That's good. Ok, so I need- oh critical breach, that doesn't sound good. I need resources.
Haaa, Spppuued (Marki-gibberish)! Idk I'm gonna die.
I gotta critical br- oh patch tape! I should probably do that. Hey! Hell ya!
"02"s going back up! I-know howda- use duck tape!
Third person view, very Mass Effect-y. Oh I kinda like this.
Oh, that's a little less jarring than first person
Ok, tool mode, yep I-ah, yep Imma tool alright
Lemme go smash my tool against this rock
And maybe I'll get something outta this.
Ahhhhhh meeeeemo box (Mark's Mating call)
Idk where there's gonna be an ammo box
Urrgh, how do I get this resource?
Tryin' to smake my tool upon it, but it no seem to work..
Op, nope, uh, Oh map! It's a separate thing, oh.
So if I go to 4,
Ahhhhhhh
So somewhere around here, there's and amer (ammo) box
Oh, build beacons to add more interest points *breath* That sounds so cool, I don't know how to dooo that.
Urgh, I'm going back.
Oh I like this mode, this gives a much more grand sense of scale because it puts a point of reference.
It's like a banana (sure Mark) you put it on your screen for scale, and you know how big the universe is (wtf?)
Oh this is cool though
There's the ammo box! I found it! I-I-Is mission control proud of me?
No?
Oh, that's why you abandoned me on this desolate planet? (Yep) Oh, I crashed. But you hoped I would survive right? (Nope)
Ohhh D:
Open ammo box. What do we got?
Ohh, ha, oughh, ha ughh (Uh, What?)
Okay sooooo-
We've got an assult riffle
S-so I don't need the patch tape anymore because I
Seem to be okay
THAT'S not what my character looked like!
That's not what my character looked like at all. (Sure, Mark)
But I got an assault riffle and I got an axe beam which
Means that i can kill some! Which is
something that I want to do A LOT.
Okay inflatable dome kid- oh! ok.
Oh, these are new things that are
dropping. Ok, one inflatable dome kit
Added to backpack, okay.
*Heavy Grunting* let's hussle we gotta build THE DOME!!
I think I should probably build the dome
Closer to over here. Let me just tell my
little bubble buddy. Okay, you gooo
Follow me
FOLLOW ME!
COME WITH ME!
You know for an early access game which I don't think
It's made by a big-name studio, this
might be I don't know the history of the
Studio but I don't know who made it.
Uh, i-i-it works out pretty well
like the animations are very fluid, the
Environment is really detailed, the the
scale of it is really impressive; I mean
Considering that I can see other planets
here, and I can see that big planted on the horizon
And I know I'm the third moon of
that planet over there. And this is a hot son of a
Bitch! So we got iron and aluminum right here,
so what I'm gonna do is I'm going toooo-
With the inflatable dome kit build awwwww *amazed*
that's cool!!
Oh that's so cool!! ooohh I love that, I love
that!
Ok so that's good enough for me haboo!
Nope *heh oo* hold action button longer to build
more health
W-why, I would want to build it with as much
help as possible
AHH
Object built at a hundred percent- oooooo it's
got a ramp it's handicap-accessible
That's good. Ok. [gasps] *singing softly* I've got a futon,
I've got a FUton!
*GASPS*
YES! Oooh I love it, okay I was trying to hold in
all the excitement because I didn't know if
this game is going to be good or not, it's-
AAWWHHH I LOVE IT!
*growls* Okay, so now that we got that- Hello
Uhh
Oh! it automatically goes to third person
as soon as I get outside. Okay, Bubble
Butt, you need to patrol since you can
survive this horrific duff (dust) storm
Over-
Over there..
Okay.
"Search for minerals to build a Forge" you
got it, bucko.
maaaan my suit is getting
dirty which is a really nice detail to add in
this game
I gotta say-
Heh hoy-ya heh-heh oiya (???)
I can't see-
eughh my god-
this space is
SOOO big!
Ooo! Is that a star up there?!
mmmm I hope so!
*Incoherent gibberish*
Now, we got iren (Iron) how do I get it?
Tool mode, missions.. 'M'
"search the planet for the right materials to start
building a Forge Utility.
The Forge is an outdoor crafting table that can,, be used to
hold complex materials that are
needed to expand to make some more
useful *inhales* and fortified settlements.
Navigate to the utilities tab inside the
Character menu to build-to view the build requirements"
Okay,
Utilllitiiees. We need a
Forge, so I need this stuff..
but I need to know how to get it..
maybe the Chisel?
oh, OF COURSE it's the chisel!
Oh, get some!
I don't know why i'm holding it
like a weapon- YEAH! Get out of here with yo bad sel-
what is that?
what-
OHH! THAT'S SO COOL!
OOOH!
I know i'm being excited
by a shadow
but shutup!
It's cool!
Oh!! It's a shadow
Of that mountain, it's not just a skybox. It's actually a thing!
Oh! That's good detail!
oh my gawwd-
I LOVE attention to detail like that, that's
cool. That's legitimately cool.
I am a hundred percent on board with that.
*heh beh*
Got ya!
Ok, so now I need some aluminium...
with my Chisel.
*boink*
*fer-brunk*
oh, it's floating in mid-air- oh no
*bambidy boom da bambidy boom*
Okay
We got more Iron
Man, it's getting hard to see
In the shadow of the mountain. heh heh heh
(yur not clever, mark)
I love my combat stance by the way..
Reeallly nice
*heh beh*
*heh bew*
*habewsky*
*hehboo*
Oh, wait encumbered?!?
ENCUMBERED?!
ENCRUMBERED?
okay, I guess I didn't
need this much Iron, so..
i'll spliiit it
and then drop the bigger stack
OK
I'm good
Alright
Comin' back
Hopefully I can build a thing now
I don't know if that's gonna be truue
Hey Bubblebutt!
You doing OK over there?
Oh man. I'm so that they gave me my own personal Bubblebutt
OK
So now we need to build a Utility.
Agh, shit
Plutonium and Titanium?
Where the heck am I gonna get those?
Can I build a beacon or something?
NOOO
Can I build furniture?
NOOOOO
Depository?
OK. I can make-
I can make a DEPOSITORY.
Oh good. I can make a
BOX
Oh I can put a BOX on the ground to put more of my.. crap in.
So I'm gonna put this depository really close by to this thing
But not to close apparently, it doesn't like that
*BOINK* Nope
Forgot about the right thing *EH*
*EH*
*MARK MAKES WHALE MATING NOISES*
What would be the benefit of not building something with maximum integrity?
I guess if you wanted it to be temporary and then not be there forever..
STORE
I don't need all of my ammo, I don't think anyway
I don't need patch tape yet
Okayy.. Vitals are already stable-
I know..
ssstore...'Cannot be removed from yo-'
Oh yeah I should probably have that on my person at all times!
I'm the idiot who thought, "Who's gonna need this in the desolate wasteland of this alien planet of mine?!"
"I'm probably not gonna' get another suit breach!" *Laughs sarcastically*
So I need- oh! Flashlight battery! I have a flashlight?!
No...that's- that's not...
'Kay so... flashlight. Where's my...Okay?
Do I not have a flashlight?
or is...
*peter griffin*
*KERCHUK*
Whoa, it is dark and desolate...Is this night now? I didn't think that it was gonna' be full night
I think it's just overcast. But I -
Oooo, wha- WHA-, WHAT IS THAT?!
WHAT THE HELL WAS THAT?!
What you kidding me?!
What the hell was that?!
It didn't even make a sound, it's just suddenly a fireball came shootin' after me!
What the HELL was that?!
We're not- we're- oh. We're not gonna' talk about that, that was just nothing then, okay, fine then.
And it's hard to see anything...
Guess I can get more IrenNN...
Eyuh! Heduh! Avast ye!
Is there any plutonium just sitting around on these hills? Soup- Suit breach?!
Suit breach?! What happened, did I hit a thorn bush?!
'Kay, use. Okay!
OH, it IS a thorn bush!
Well, I know how to play two games with one stone!
Ah shit, maybe I shouldnt waste ammo..
GIVE ME YOUR ALLIMUM
GIMMIE YOUR ALIMONY
Marry me, and then lemme divorce ya (don't think it works that way Mark)
*EUGH EUGH EUGH EH*
HI!
*Grunt that could be likened to what Mark will sound like in 5 years*
Ima getcha eventually...
HYO! Got it :D
Ok
Got you
ooh no
all my aluminium rolled to the bottom of the hill
Get you
Get you..
Am I encumbered yet?
No, I can still carry more
OK
More Aluminium!
*bewsh!*
ha-
*haaa-bewski*
okay
get that-get that-get that
Okay-
wooah, that look's cool
OKAY!
Headed back,
I need to put some lights on that 'sum bitch..
wonder if I can build lights...?
I can probably build lights!
"Suit Temperature High" ?
What can I do about that?
i'm just so hot.. (very true Mark)
Stoore
SSStore-- actually
let me pull some of this..
baaaaack
CAUSE!
If I buuuillld,
I built an inflatable dome, but that was just
because I had the materials beforehand.
so,
I doubt it's gonna give me anything
but I need a Forge,
which means I need Titanium.
Awh, man
there's no lights
beacon? that might do it
chRemistry table,
Yeah.. I don't have anything for that
Climate controller? *whisper* holy shit
Computer Desk, that'd be nice to look up all my pooorn.
Better than a Futon, I suppose
but I don't have any rOOber
So, I just-
I just need to go out and get Titanium, and Plutonium,
I need to stop being such a little BITCH
and get this shit-
Ba
So i'm gonna store all this-
Hover fuel
Hover Fuel?
can I hover?
[Realization gasp]
i'm Iron-Man!
HOOO LOOK AT ME GO!
Ooooh-
That's so cool!
Oh, that's so cool
Beeh
imma skatin'
Imma skatin' alone!
OK, so I need to use the map
...Probably
to actually find something good,
Cause there seems to be
death all around me
but,
where I is,
there is nothing to help me
so somewhere here..
Is gonna be..
Theres gonna be some
SWEET
DANK
Something
or other
OH, It's raining!
I didn't-
I didn't think there would be rain
on this desolate planet
oooh jeez-
Well that sounds bad,
Is something gonna happen?
is something-
*mewl*
Me no likey that
can't see where i'm going
can'T SeE where i'm goING
"Suit Temperature High"
Which just means i'm running too much..
so the map says
There's like a drop-off or something
over here
AND they would be very correct!
There is one hell of a drop-off
Holy shit.
I don't know if I can survive that
I dont know if im supposed to survive that
PRETTYSURE
this is supposed to be a deturnent for me
going that way
Well shit
what is that over there?
Woah-
What's with the shadowy figures?
Is that-
That good or bad?
IMMA GO TOWARDS IT!
BUT THE OMINOUS MUSIC SEEMS TO
BE CRESCENDOING FROM THIS DIRECTION
Im going to get my assault-rifle out just in case
it IS an alien planet
and who knows how-
how many Hostiles might
be here
OH
[tiny gasp]
whats that?
OOOO
Is that something?!
CARBON?!
ooo
Okay
I'm getting into resources
Is that like a forest over there??
ookay
I'm going down in the pit
this doesnt seem like a very safe thing to do
Hydrogen Geyser!
That sounds nice
Okay, good
Okay, i'll get some Carbon
I'll take some sweet dank Carbon-
*HEH*
*DABOOSKI*
Okay
I got some carb on
eugh
eeegh
there we go
Okay, so, where did I see
more Carbon over here
I don't like this goop
God, I wish I could see
hoW DO I TURN ON MY GOD DAMN-
ugghhhh
how do I turn on my god damn flashlight?
i'm such an idiot
*bam*
*ga bam*
there we go!
okay!
How much space I got?
PLENTY OF SPACE! I got 44 Carbon which should be good enough for Mmmost of what I need
I dont have the means with which to..
contain that Hydrogen I don't think
yeah, Hydrogens not gonna do anything
okay, so there's gotta be something else somewhere else
I guess I could go towards that forest?
where ever that is..
Looks like a forest
or something
It's such a bizarre feeling
venturing into the unknown
I mean, I- I love this thing about
y'know
about games like this
Espcecially space games, just because
I have no idea what's out there!
I have no idea if there's anything even t-to threaten me!
and yet i'm,
really, really anxious right now
a-and that's a cool feeling to have
*peeww*
almost shoot whatever comes out at me
what the hell is that thing?
"Oxygen Critical"
Okay, I gotta camp out for a bit.
HAVEN'T FOUND ANY PLATONIUM!
I'm never gonna get back to my camp at this point.
okay
nooow
we're getting close..
and it does seem to be some sort of mushroom forest, it reminds me of the mushroom forest
down in subnautica
in the uh, zangar...
region
or whatever it was called.
?? rubber tr-
OH! RUBBER!
It's a rubber tree!
It's a whole tree made out of rubber!
Can I get it??
*heh*
Heeeey
Yeeaaahh
Okay!
I can just wail on this thing forever
it's gonna give me all the rubber I need!
's gonna give me so much rubbuh
oh, rubber takes up nothing i'll get two stacks
Oh, no, maybe more
might as well
Seems like actions are faster in First Person mode
but it's not as aesthetically pl-
IS THE SUN GONNA COME OUT YET?!
I MEAN, MY GOD, IM TIRED OF THIS OVERCAST DREARINESS
okay, how many stacks?
over 4 more rubber
There we go
that's uh...
No, two more
there we go
THAT'S A FULL FOUR STACKS
Okay, so now I just need
some gersh dern
something or other
I g- I guess I shoud head back. because I don't know
where else to go
and this- this hovering is kinda nice because it saves me some energy when i'm sprinting
because I still do the same
*breaks*
Hellloooo!
Whooooeeuuggh
Heeey!
Heeeey!
There IS other life here
Let's kill it! (great logic)
ooo, it's bar is red so im pretty sure that means 'Bad'
Right?
eugh
Hey Buddeh
Hey budd-eh
Hey budde- zoooom
hey buddeh-
wo-o-o-wo-weh woah woah woah woah woah WOAH woah WOAH
HAHHH
holy shit
He ASS-ploded
"Alien Meat" okay
YES! I AM A THREAT TO YOUR PLANET
I CAME HERE TO CONQUER!
IF YOU HAVE ANY WOM-EN
BETTER HIDE THEM
I'M CLIMBING IN YOUR WINDOWS
HIDE YOUR HUS-BANDS, TOO!
Well the music definitely didn't like the fact that I killed one of their
"Creatures"
one of their Gentle Creatures™ of this planet just died
and now someone seems unhappy
but i'm gonna make my way back to camp with the resources that I got
uhhmm
man, it-it says it wants me to complete the habitat structure
so, I might do that first and then maybe it'll give me a better idea
where I can get Plutonium-- woah
Something was down there
something ALIVE
Something amongst the carbon
I saw something
Woah- Hey- Woah Woah Woah
That looks big
woahh
Woah nelly
young crab monster
Im- I- Im glad that it's name literally says 'Monster' cause I-
OOOooooo
I hiteded its
*sings* braain
probably
Dead Young Crab Monster
"Raid Dead Creature" oh i'm gonna raid it
got dat alien meat
MMMM
I ate these potatoes
I've evolved past the need for taters D:
Ahhh, that didnt sound good
OHH
Larvus--- *gibberish*
what was that?
*sing songy* ooooh that doesnt look good
Oh Jeez
Oh god- Well at least now it's day
Holy shit, I can see
My god, this place is infested
euugh
ogay *okay*
where the hell is my god damn BASE??
WHERE THE HELL IS BUBBLEBUTT?
HOW DID I GET LOST?!
Well I know how I got lost -- everything looks the god damn same
oh jeez
ok, goodbyee!
Oh, there's more
Oh of-course there's more!
Of-course there's more!
I didn't see any on the way in
I must of crossed over some weirrrd territory here!
Cause i am not
in the right spots
you wanna geeh you wanna go brah
Ha you wanna go uh too bad fur you
K gimme that alien meat!
So it wasn't over there! It definitely wasn't over there!
But this map doesn't look any familiar
and i cant zoom out!
uh im screewweedd
oh im so screwed
What is that, that looks glowy thats not carbon
Thats not carbon, That aint Falco
That is COPper. YES I'LL TAKE SOME COPPER!
Hell Yeh!
Come at me Coppa,
Ehh
Ha Swee
Ha Swoo
Ok got it-got it-got it
Gimme Gimme Gimme Gimme Gimme Gimme Gimme Gimme Gimme GIMME
OK
Got da copper
Oh-im outta here and i can see which is nice
So I-I-I the weird thing is I don't even see the original like
stone peaks that i saw before
I mean its definitely wasn't that broken one. I would've noticed if it was broken like that
Oh get out the way no ah i'm running low on oxygen
Heh, gotta use my zoom-y technique. I'm outta here!!
UHH NOW ITS NIGHT AGAIN YOU TELLING ME THAT WHOLE CYCLE
WAS JUST BECAUSE IT WAS GLOOMY AND RAINY!!
OH GOD DAMMIT I AM UNLUCKY ON THE GETTING OF LIGHT!
Oh stop being in that god dam stance, ohh shit
Kay got ya
i got 1 exsp
I don't need your body
Maybe it was over there, maybe it was over that way?
Maybe thats the way i went
Yeah that might of been it that seems more likely because
Yeah i think i just, i think i just went a different direction on the way back
Mmm cause i couldn't see anything...
Ok what about does there there didn't seem to be any yeah does not require additional ammo
so ima going to bring out the good old pistol-y pist
ok nevermind im goind to bring this out to the multi tool because
ba i dont know what the multi tool does at this point besides probably build
And then ima use this because it comes with unlimited ammro *ammo*
HAH
Call this "the game of not being able to see shit!!*
DAA
Im frustrated
I like it. No, I like there fact that there is weather and the day-night cycle that is really cool don't get me wrong
But I just feel like i am being unfairly
Targeted by this bull-shit
I just want to make it back to camp so i can...
Fucking...
DEYAH
AH i see it in the distance i think i see bubble butt too
Yeah this is definitely it
MAYBE IT WILL BE DAY BY THE TIME I GET BACK!!!
OK Im finally back at my camp which is nice but
still I-I didn't get what I needed I-I don't have my god damn PLUTONIUM!
*groans*
[Reading] Search for minerals to build an airlock
OH, I don't have..
No, I don't want to skip THEse! *groans* I don't want to skip these!
I didn't- OH NO!!
Oh! I've been skipping misSIONS!!
OHHH! That's not what I wanted at AALLL!
Oh no..
Oh dang it..
Oh dingus dang..
Oh, I- I did bad..
Oh, I did bad!.. Okay.
So I've got a problem.
I can't build this because I don't have any plutonium..
AND I don't know where to get plutonium.
And its
god damn perpetual
DARKNESS.
[soft frustration yell]
It's been perpetually dark!
Oh, man...
And somehow,
It turn on a flashlight
WELL, I don't know HOW?!
HOW DO YOU TURN ON A FLASHLIGHT?!
uhhh
How do I turn on a flashlight?
How?! It's all I want to know??
THE ONE THING I CAN'T USE TO BEAT THE DARKNESS
IS A GOD DAMN FLASHLIGHT!!!
I DON'T KNOW!!
I'm pushing all the buttons
Oh..
[gun shot]
Ah fucking
Ah, fucking. What the hell did you come from?
oh geez
You look terrifying. I'd love to know
how to fuckin' look at ya!
What button did I just push??
What button did I push?
Oh, I don't know what button I pushed
God damn it!
(mouth sounds)
Oh, now I can see ya!
Oh, now you're looking really bad..
Oh, geez! You look scare-we
Okay
I'm crouched too apparently..
ZIP! Oh shit. Oh, ya missed me.
Oh, you're dead. Okay.
geez-ums
What button did I push?!?
It's L.
LLLL!
FOR LIGHT!
L- STAAAAAY!!!
Woah! What the
fuck?
Okay
So now that I have solved that mystery,
Geez. I'm sorry!
I thought I pushed every button!
I went- I pushed all the buttons!
Oh and now I think dawn is breaking...
Okay. So..
Whoo
I did not accomplish much in this
I know-I know that- I know that!
This is a horrible start to this game :/
but I love it!
I don't love my start;
I love this game.
It has a lot of potential here.
And I don't know
how detailed it is.
When I'm looking at the build list,
it doesn't seem too complex.
When I look at the utilities,
there's only a few things here.
When I look at the furniture,
you know, I'm not too terribly impressed.
It seems like a lot of storage and just basic survival stuff.
But that's though the reason
why this is early access
because it's got the potential
the framework- HEY! God damn it!
What are you?!
What are you??
"Infant Giant". Oh, good!
It's a small giant!
Oh, thank you Bubble-butt. I should have had you following me..
Okay.
I'm gonna get in my.. I'm gonna get in my god damn habitat.
So that I can get away from this. And I can do the suit breach thing..
YOUS
CLOSE
Okay.
And then
SAVE.
Woah, Nelly!
But there's a lot of potential.
The framework here is for something really impressive.
It all depends on what the developer wants to put in it
further to make it even bigger and better
So, it's available on Steam right now on early access. I think it was like $25.
But in the next episode,
And I am gonna do another one because I know that I need to redeem myself for this one.
I'm gonna do multiplayer
and see who I can join
on my
horrifying adventures in space.
So Thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always, I will see you
in the next video- HOLY SHIT
Bu-bye!
[Ostrich monster dancing to the Horror Outro]
(Does anybody know how to make subtitles like this?)
Isn't he tangoing nicely with Mark?
How graceful.
Such elegance.
Such poise.
But now he's dead.